I remember the first video kind of
started off with me like being super
concerned about like if my hair was okay
or not I thought that was funny like I
have you know bigger problems to worry
about and to talk about but like here I
am talking about oh it's my hair okay
you look fine you look good but what
what's what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle that you've been living for
how many years now have youve been uh I
started when I was 19 so in your now I'm
28 almost 29 so you're almost 10 years
into this craziness yeah it'll be a
decade of chaos but you know three out
of the last four years I've I have been
like actually like clean and sober from
like everything were those years
better um those years were
definitely better is like not the right
word they
were they they made more sense like you
know this lifestyle doesn't make as much
sense it's like
um there's more consistency in those
years uh I get more done but you know
yesterday I actually got some done
I went to the SSI office and got a new
social coming in the mail I went to the
bank have a new debit card coming in the
mail so I got you know some things done
I'm functioning somewhat you know
definitely more than the first time that
I saw
you I mean so many people yeah that are
in this lifestyle you you think just a
little bit of Common Sense will get you
to get clean to get your life together
to get your driver's license or whatever
you need right so you can get moved
forward in your life but instead of that
happening the next day you see them and
like oh my tent caught on fire and I
lost this and I got robbed and I like
they they're standing around with one
shoe
and no belongings you know being on this
street now I'm not actually on the
street it's been almost 2 months now
that I've been house through a housing
program something similar to project
room key so you have housing now yeah
I'm My Own Room my own bathroom I have a
dog does that help oh my God
tremendously you know I'm so grateful
for you know the mayor she's the one who
opened up this facility and like put on
this
program um you know with without like
the the structure of having a place to
go that is safe safe and to be able to
shower and just like
uh maintain a certain look so that you
know I'm not judged on the street for
being you know a drug addict or like
homeless um I could cross homeless off
of you know
that that Sigma now I still you know
could be stigmatized for being a drug
addict I'm I'm open about it uh probably
too open like on your you know Channel
talking you know to hundreds of
thousands of people about it but like I
I that's how I've always been I've
always just you know I it's been hard
for me to ever lie or like to to hide
anything about myself so like there are
times where like I say things where you
know I probably shouldn't but it I I
just do because it's the truth you what
I've learned through doing so many of
these interviews I've seen people like
like Patrick who was a crack addict that
I interviewed several times yeah he was
probably the most honest of anybody I've
interviewed just laying out all his
dirty laundry for the world to see and
his life has done a complete 180 like
everything he's walking a very straight
line he just got married wow a month or
two ago and his his life is looks so
different than it did when I first
interviewed him and I think that's
because of how brutally honest he was
right so it's like he doesn't have
anything hidden in the closet any longer
right there's nothing for him to hide
nothing for him to be ashamed about
already told the whole world about it
right and it it freed him up I think to
I'm not saying I'm not video his honesty
with himself yeah allowed him to move
forward so he said he's married is he
clean to he's clean yeah wow okay yeah
I'm not there yet you know a lot of
people want me to get clean but the
thing is like you have to want it for
yourself
um I just you know where where I hate to
be the person making excuses but where
I'm living it's I it's too hard so I'm
just and you know I'm not going to put
myself through that like you know
hopefully you know not I'm just going to
speak into existence I am going to get
my own place you know it's a it's a
program that gets you Section 8 I'm
going to get my own place I get to
choose where uh I live I'm going to
choose an area that is not so toxic you
know somewhere where maybe I have
recovered before like in Santa Monica
where there's great
recovery um I was there for like four
months in a program and I've been to you
know meetings on the beach um there's
you know a great Fellowship out there
and a community college that is great
that I have had friends go to you know
after they got sober so I see that for
myself and you know I you know I'm going
to try to manifest it that's the way to
do it yeah I just don't think like the
complete sobriety like being you know
clean off of everything is going to
happen for me until I'm you know out of
this
area yeah cuz I'm pretty close to Skid R
still just being around this the buzz of
this yeah dysfunction right sucks you in
all my neighbors you know everybody in
the hotel that I live in you know maybe
not everybody but like pretty much
everybody is is a user and I'm
surrounded by it um um just you know
walking down the street like you know
when I go out and take my dog for a
walks it's it's around the Alvarado area
you know I live close to Alvarado so
like are you tempted oh yeah and like
I'm not I I just get into it you know
I'm not going to fight it I know you
know I people tell me that I'm stronger
than I think I am and you know maybe
that's true but like
I I don't know I I guess I don't believe
in myself as much as others
do um Can can you talk to me about how
difficult it is to just stop using this
drug that you know is bad for you yeah
you know it's going to destroy your life
but absolutely what is it that tomorrow
you might just use again what why is
that well mainly because I don't want to
get sick I would have to go through a
detox your drug is um it's meth it's uh
in Downers so it's there there's a
little bit of fanel and um that's hard
um but this time it's more so benzo's so
I would have to go like benzo withdraw
is like to me I think the the scariest
is the best word for it you know it's
scary yeah so that's not going to be
easy to get off no that would have to
I'd have to go through a medical like
detox process where like yeah I'm weaned
off and luckily though I have a case
worker and um through the Department of
Mental Health um we just had scheduled
an appointment and you know there's a
weit you know it's a government program
but like they are going to be able to
taper me you know and get me off and
it's going to be hard because they're so
cheap you know I think that's why I
prefer over Fetti is because I could you
know get aill Hill for $2 rather than
having to you
know have $20 to buy a sack cuz some
people W like sell if you have 20 bucks
you know but what was your darkest point
when you were deep in your
addiction
probably last Janu well a couple months
before I did that first interview you
living on the street yeah I was on the
street it's before I gone to the
National Health
Foundation um it's before I gotten the
knee infection I think when I got the
knee infection that was my lowest moment
cuz like I I physically couldn't
function you know like it it was bad you
know luckily it didn't get to my joints
but Cedar sin like shot Ser SI because
they really took care of me they really
did I stayed there for like a week and
then I was you know housed and then
after being house for a little while I
decided to with the help of some friends
um I was scholarship and I was able to
get into detox and do a
full um it was supposed to be 90 days
but then it ended up being like a four
or five month
scholarship uh so when you're in a
hospital and you're a fentel addict at
the time yes what what does the hospital
do so it wasn't you it wasn't it was a
that's that would be like if I was to
get so now without a scholarship luckily
like I know so many people who work in
the uh
in recovery in in rehabs so it was a
scholarship to a private but you were in
the hospital for your knee infection oh
yeah yeah yeah and what what how did
they handle the fact that you were
addicted to a Dr a street drug
so God I snuck in my torch and my Dabber
and my like little silicone and I it did
not last long so when I ran out I had to
tell somebody you know I was scared and
I was embarrassed uh but they treated
they treated it and they handled it so
well compared to other hospitals like I
didn't feel stigmatized they they put me
on like
oxy
hydrocodone and like uh
volume um there was a nurse that that
that was going to start me so their
experience with dealing with people in
that situation definitely yeah yeah they
were going to put me on methadone
luckily I didn't get you know I was on
it for like a week like at a small dose
because you take it and then each day
you increase and people like in you know
increase to the point where like you
know you're high and then like it get
that that drug has such a long half
lifee it seeps into your bone marrow
like that's harder to get off of than
fentanyl by a long shot so I'm glad that
didn't happen um King fretty honestly
isn't like that hard like you know it's
more of a mental thing but like kicking
B
it's it's scary like there's a seizure
risk I I had to do it once um where I
went to a a I went to jail in you know
the boonies of
Indiana um after being on kinin for two
years and like they they don't give you
anything at this jail there's no
taper so you're still young do you have
do you have dreams of doing something
with your life absolutely yeah what
would you like to
do that is like there's so much I want
to do you know I don't want to have kids
I want to startare with that I don't
want to have
kids um I want to go back to school I
want to take it I want you know baby
steps I want to you know first go to
Community
College maybe become a nurse
or you know some sort of helping
profession it is hard you know with with
this being out there though you know but
um I can delete it no I mean yeah you
could you don't have to post it it's up
to you no but the first one yeah you
could if you want me to one day just let
me know really oh yeah nice because I
don't want to get in the way of your
forward progress right if something like
that is slowing you down yeah I just
actually like when I left and came back
here like I was in sober living with the
guy who was a nurse actually um and he
he was very secretive about it like he
he said he was away for like his alcohol
addiction so like it's not out there
that he was actually you know using like
math I think these stories are so common
yeah see I might need you to delete it
in like four years yeah yeah let me and
I'll let you know I'll say make sure I
save your contact I'll get it a tattooed
this time it hard to find it Well I'm
easy to find you just go to my channel
there's an email at the top yeah I know
I tried emailing and like I don't know
uh does it go to like somebody that
works for you yeah yeah I I don't know I
got end up getting it from Jordan who
has a video on your channel right he he
saved your number and it was just easier
that way you probably would have
eventually gotten back to me vi email um
I'm it's on my YouTube channel yeah
so so I hope you can figure this out
yeah definitely um and you've been
through programs more than once yeah the
programs just aren't they're not for
every
they're not for everybody and I think
it's a system that kind of is set up to
be a revolving door you know and it is a
business there's a business aspect to it
um if people if everybody was to get
clean then like there would be out of
business no business you know there
people lose jobs and like these people
make a lot of money you know um there's
body brokering um at some places some
facilities that you know treat humans
like objects you know you know just to
you know gain them incentive and after
that you know I I I've known stories of
people getting paid and to go go out and
get high and uh then after getting high
they're supposed to come and do their
intake you know and then have something
in their system so that insurance uh
verifies and pays out but they die you
know they're given the drugs and then
that you know before they go do their
intake they die because you know they do
too much
um it's a pretty horrifying life isn't
it yeah you see so much terrible stuff
on the street and yeah even even in
treatment you see it yeah it's crazy I'm
used to the chaos like it's really
different now like having like a
tranquil space space where I've been
able to like make it my own and like you
know uh decorate and organize my dad had
sent me like for Christmas a Marshall's
gift card and a friend sent me a Target
gift card I actually like didn't use
these gift cards to like I didn't sell
them you know for drugs like I bought
things for my space to make it
comfortable for me and you know to I you
know luckily I was given a big space
like a uh a double room so like I extra
space to um get furniture you know cuz I
am playing to when they have an
apartment and um I do have you know high
hopes for myself I don't want to get too
far ahead of myself and start tripping
but like there you know there's
something I can't pinpoint it but I I
feel like there's something great that
I'm going going to do you know I think
that you know I just don't know exactly
what it is M you some people know and I
just just got to get this monkey off
your back right right and
it's I have the support
and when I'm ready you know I know I'll
be able to do it it's it's just hard
because like I don't know I've tried so
many times
and I've had long you know long periods
to me long periods are 6 months uh 8
months 9 months like that and then like
going back you know that's the issue but
it's a lifelong thing you know I have to
remind myself that and not be too hard
on myself um it's a lifelong illness and
um but at a certain point I think I'm
going to you know grow tired of it you
know I'm getting
older like 30 is like technically like G
gay death that's what they
say I don't even think like you know
funny it's is funny it's stupid but like
I don't know people like in this area La
especially that's Hollywood that scene
makes such a big deal about like the way
you look and your appearance and being
looking youthful and you know Botox you
know procedures skin care whatever face
lifts you know and I get it you know
people want to be seen and people want
to be you know is the gay lifestyle more
shallow or or competitive like that yeah
so I worked I worked like in the gay bar
scene like over where like all the gay
bars are on uh St Monica and Robertson
and like at that time my eating disorder
was the worst you know I think it's ever
been that's when I was actually in
treatment for eating disorder and I
think you know there is like a
competitiveness to it you know like like
there's a standard I feel like we are
all gay uh gay people I like when I say
we like gay people um we all have a
underlying shame um shame of Shame of
what shame of uh just growing up and
being being told it's changing but like
you know the older ones and like even
people of My
Generation Um being told
that we
[Music]
aren't like who we are isn't uh right
you know so there's shame you know like
we should be more masculine you know or
we should we should like girls we should
be you know doing this or that or having
interests that are more like you know
typical like you know Sports whatever um
I think that is going away and there are
you know you know gay gay children who
are being raised um and who are healthy
and I think think like the uh statistics
for uh drug addiction in uh the LGBT
population I think uh they they are
going
[Music]
to
uh like be less you know like it's the
rate of people being addicted because it
is very common you know drugs in the gay
community especially Crystal math right
yeah I think Addiction in my community
is going to you
um I don't know I think it's like the
times are changing and it's going to be
re revolutionized I believe that like
you know there's always going to be
people addicted to drugs but you know I
don't think as many people are going to
because that it all comes from that
underlying shame you know I think that
I'm bad that's what shame is you know
it's interesting yeah there's like a
saying it's like like when it comes to
shame and guilt it's
like guilt is like I did something bad
and shame is I am bad um and then
believing that to the root in your core
you know when like your brain is
developing you know especially around
like the age of like seven um that just
like sticks with you and like so like to
change that mindset and shift it like
and you know to tell yourself that you
you aren't bad you are okay
as who you are um it's tough and it
takes time it takes work and I think
like as a community a gay the gay commun
as a whole should really you know come
together more and put less emphasis on
you know the way we look you know and
focus more on like our mental health and
like you know um raising the next
Generations to not hate themselves mhm
because they might have like a you know
a little more fat than like the average
person you know there's a lot of things
I have shame for you know other than
being gay you know it's not just a gay
thing it's there's there's body issues
like uh I compare myself to everyone and
everything like like one of my previous
best friends who won't like talk to me
anymore like I just dm'd him and he was
like I'm not talking to you if you're
using you know there's people like that
uh who like completely like shut me out
um but like he's like you know G gained
gay Fame because he's started doing porn
so like he'll go out and be
recognized and you know I'm pretty sure
he's on
steroids but he's clean and sober I
guess you know a lot of people in the
gate like like this is going to be like
people are going to hate me for saying
this but like a lot of like gay sober
people do steroids like
in like I guess they're they're sober I
mean they're not doing math but
like steroids are that's a drug right
yeah I don't know if it's addictive but
it probably could be psychologically
addictive I think so yeah I've done them
before I've done steroids with a friend
that passed away what did they do for
you at first they like enhance your uh
energy levels in your libido so it
almost reminds you of like if you have a
crystal meth addiction it can trigger
that for sure because it gives you more
energy and you gain muscle fast so like
and that could be addictive like valid
then what happened over time oh God over
time uh you destroy
your how do you pronounce it Endo Endo
endocine yeah that whole system yeah you
have to be put on testosterone for the
rest of your life like you could grow
you know man boo as they say it um it's
just not good for you of time I I've
I've heard stories of a guy I had a
friend that worked in a detox where a
guy in the detox his heart exploded
because of his addiction and his use of
um his abuse of steroids he had a heart
attack like and his heart like literally
exploded while he like the first day he
got there or he was like you know
planning to get
yeah well no no no it happened in sober
living so like he went through detox and
then started using steroids and that's
how he
died seems like everybody's altering
their their chemistry somehow right you
know and that happened at the yeah I
shouldn't say that but like it happens
in a lot of places like we just we we
just want anything that makes us feel
you know outside of ourselves you know
nicotine caffeine even you know
everybody goes like Starbucks in the
coffee industry is like crazy you know
how much play they make it's just like
anything to get you out of like yourself
you know yeah because to be stuck in in
on especially when like you have mental
health issues and like you
know right now I'm at a place where like
thank God I had the dog I like I got a
dog because like without that
responsibility and
like you know it the dog is like
something outside myself that like I
could you know take care of a positive
thing that isn't you know drugs you know
and it gets me outside myself like I you
know I take care of it I feed it I take
it on walks I buy it clothes it has like
11 outfits now like I I don't know I
don't know if they sell like mini uh Co
coat rocks and like mini hangers well
they do probably do because they have
the hangers for babies you know or the
hangers they come with but I want to get
like a rack like that is like tiny and
just like have a wardrobe just for him I
met so many people who've given me
outfits for him and like I don't know he
likes it though some people say like oh
you you know that's like you know why
are you doing that to your Amo like you
know you're just like using the mess an
accessory mine is like Chihuahua like
like a half Chihuahua so like he Shivers
and he loves he loves his sweaters you
know he gets excited he starts to wag
his tail and like he he shoves his head
through like a turtleneck you know like
I'm not forcing him to work close all
right Kenneth thank you so much for
coming back and checking in with us
definitely it's cool it's been a minute
now it's cool to update you know yeah
know you and just see you again in like
the evolution of your channel and things
you doing hope you figure this out thank
you you have so much potential thank you
so much you just have to see it and take
advantage
it thank you Mark thank you kenth
okay